the scene in Germany after the final
whistle it followed a nerve-racking
scoreless battle that wasn't decided
until the final minutes of extra time
for jubilant fans in Berlin there was no
holding back many took to their cars to
get out on the streets and share in the
public party thousands of revelers
flocked on to Berlin's kurfürstendamm
clogging the streets and blocking the
road only tonight no one was in a hurry
to get anywhere anyway Germany best team
in the world yes 4 stars 4 stars
brilliant brilliant we won the 2014
World Cup but for argentineans of the
German capital the party had been
brought to an abrupt end mr. always I'm
not sad and I'm not happy at least we
played well back on the kurfürstendamm
the party was just beginning for many
had promised to be a long night
we want a party we're going to have a
drink party walk around we're going to
party till the Sun comes up meanwhile
Germany's newspapers rolled off the
presses later than usual they only went
to print after the results came in from
Rio on the front page the German world
champions it was a short night for
newspapers seller Eric sellin to who
opened up at five in the morning Yugi
nothing also we expect to sell every
paper with football in it today who's by
roseville and within just moments of
opening the first German fan arrives to
buy his copy for posterity